samsung has been on a roll lately
putting out four sets of wireless
earbuds
in less than two years each one with
significant improvements compared to the
last
including these new galaxy buds pro if
you buy them
most of you will be really happy so why
is it that i'm having a hard time
recommending them
after using them extensively every day
for a week now
and what are the two problems that i've
personally experienced
with them that's exactly what you'll
find out after watching this review
as well as which earbuds i would
recommend instead of these and why
which are also linked down in the video
description below let's start out with
the good
and the first thing that really stands
out is the sound quality
samsung is once again using dual drivers
like in the galaxy buds plus
but they've redesigned them and you
could definitely hear the difference
listening to them side by side they
promised balanced sound
and wide frequency response with rich
bass silky treble
and a wide sound stage now i would agree
to almost
all of that the dual drivers definitely
provide deep rich bass and that treble
stands out
particularly in songs with a lot going
on such as rock music where these
provide
great instrument separation and clear
vocals the only
thing that i wouldn't agree to is their
claim of a wide soundstage
now it's not bad but it's nothing
special and samsung's own
galaxy buds lives are noticeably better
if you care about this
these things sound fantastic for earbuds
and after using these for a bit it is
tough to go back to my earpods pro
because of the lower sound quality the
difference is very noticeable
with that if you're an iphone or a mac
user i had no problems using these
they paired without any issue and they
connected consistently and quickly
pretty much right away every time i
pulled them out of their charging case
of course you won't get all of the
features on an iphone such as 360 degree
sound
which is similar to apple's spatial
audio or the ability to read out
messages and having a hands-free
assistant
but if you don't care about these things
they worked great
and they also had great range and the
sound quality was indistinguishable
compared to when i had them connected to
my galaxy note 20. now samsung
still hasn't updated their galaxy buds
app for ios
but thankfully these earbuds sound the
best in their default normal mode
so no need to go into the app in order
to change the eq like you had to do with
the galaxy buds plus for the gamers out
there these have about 300 milliseconds
of latency which isn't great
and it's right there right at the line
of being usable
depending on the game and how picky you
are but it is a good improvement
compared to the previous versions
and surprisingly the performance is the
same on the iphone
even though you don't have that gaming
toggle what really stands out is
watching videos and especially movies on
these
where of course there is no latency
because of the improved dual drivers
the rich deep bass is much closer to a
real surround sound system than most
earbuds
and all of those really low sounds that
shake you in an action scene
are actually immersive and they pull you
into the film and with that the vocals
are still
very clear and easy to understand
instead of being muffled by the action
apple please use dual drivers and your
airpods pro 2.
it will take your excellent spatial
audio to the next
level and with that apple please copy
their voice detect feature this is one
of my favorite new features which allow
you to keep active noise cancellation
enabled
and when you start talking they will
automatically go into the ambient mode
and stay there until you don't talk for
about 10 seconds
in real world use this usually worked
really well and 10 seconds was enough
of a buffer for most conversations it
does take about 2 seconds for them to
switch from the time you start talking
and i did have a few times where they
would switch back too early
so it would be nice to be able to adjust
this to say maybe 30 seconds
but this feature is definitely not a
gimmick with that the ambient mode
actually sounds pretty good being a big
improvement compared to the buds plus
and the default normal mode sounds the
most natural
i think a big part of this is because of
the much better microphones
take a listen for yourself to how the
mic compares to the galaxy buds plus
and my earpods pro this is the
microphone quality of the galaxy buds
plus
this is a microphone quality that you
can expect with samsung's new
galaxy buds pro and this is the
microphone quality with apple's airpods
pro
in real world use i didn't have a single
phone call where the person on the
opposite side
had a hard time hearing me even when i
was in loud environments
and each time i asked how i sounded they
responded that my voice was clear and
easy to hear
great job samsung that is a big
improvement another strong point
is battery life now sure they can't
touch the crazy 11 hours or so
with the galaxy buds plus but i don't
expect any earbuds with active noise
cancellation to last
that long and samsung's claims of about
5 hours with anc on
is spot on and the buzz charge really
quickly
when you put them into their charging
case together you get a total of up to
28 hours of use
but that claim is based on use without
active noise cancellation
with it on it's more like about 18 hours
which is still very good
and i only had to charge twice in the
last week simply by placing the case on
a wireless charging pad for a few hours
while using the buds and then they are
good to go speaking of the charging case
samsung ditched the older longer style
and they're using a square case like the
galaxy buds live came with
but with a few updates the earbuds are
easier to place in
and both of the magnets that hold the
buds and the ones that hold the lid
are quite a bit stronger personally i
miss the older shape since it took up
less width in my pocket
which is really nice especially if you
have a wallet in that pocket but for
most people it won't matter and the case
is fairly small compared to many other
brands
one of the ways that the pros stand out
compared to samsung's older earbuds and
most that are on the market
are their waterproofing rating these are
rated ipx7 which means that they can be
fully submerged
in over three feet of water for 30
minutes and they should still work
that is way better than the previous
ones which are rated mostly for splashes
but even though they have this rating
samsung still doesn't recommend using
them
on the beach or in pools and if they get
damaged it doesn't seem like samsung
will replace them
still having this rating gives way more
confidence
that they will hold up great when
working out or if you're using them
outside
say in the rain or the snow so that was
a lot of talk about the good things that
the new pros offer
but what are the two problems that i
talked about and
why is it hard for me to recommend these
the first issue i found when using them
is long-term comfort when i first tried
them on they were surprisingly
comfortable because samsung redesigned
the silicon tips so they are much
thicker and with that it's mostly just
the tips that go into your ears
just like the airpods pro and also with
that they added an
air vent to release pressure build up
similar once again to the airpods pro
these definitely improved the in-ear
comfort but that's not where i had an
issue the actual buds themselves
increased in size quite a bit
filling in the space in your ear so that
they can fit all the new tech in there
while not having them stick out of your
ear any more than before
because of this after about an hour and
a half my ear starts hurting where the
buds pro
touch and after about two hours i have
to take a break from using them
and i'm not typically someone who has an
issue with earbud fit
regular earpods were great for me as do
the pros
the sony's and the same thing with the
galaxy buds live so it's a bummer that
these aren't working out
and i can't use them as long as i can
with other earbuds
now this might not be an issue for you
but since they are
quite big if you have smaller ears i
would definitely keep this in mind
my next problem is the active noise
cancellation
it does work and it works better than
the galaxy buds live which are only
useful in select environments
which led me to call their ink more of a
marketing tool than an actual useful
feature
my issue is that it doesn't work well
enough for earbuds that cost
200 and it's only slightly better than
the galaxy buds plus
which have no cancellation whatsoever
and they block out a ton of noise
simply because they have a sealed design
without an air vent the airpods pro
noise cancellation is
noticeably better and the sonys are even
better than that
because of this if you're looking at the
galaxy buds pro for their noise
cancellation
i wouldn't count on it being great and
if that's the main reason for buying
them
over the galaxy buds plus i wouldn't do
it with that the main reason why i can't
recommend these
is because of how good the galaxy buds
plus are
and because of the price where you can
currently get them for 109
brand new and under 80 refurbished
which is a shockingly good price for
those i'll go ahead and leave links down
in the video description to those deals
now sure the galaxy bud pros do sound
better and they have a better microphone
but is it worth paying double for those
improvements and then having slightly
less noise
in some environments honestly no
i don't think so and with that if you
want comfort and even better sound
quality than the galaxy buds pro
and you don't need to block out noise
check out the galaxy buzz live
which are now 140 bucks or possibly even
less when you're watching this video
i'll go ahead and link those down below
as well overall the galaxy buds pro
are great earbuds and i have very little
complaints if they fit your ears
and dropping 200 for them doesn't hurt
your wallet
you will really enjoy them but seeing
how fast samsung is releasing new ones
i bet will soon have some that are more
comfortable and have
way better active noise cancellation go
ahead and click over there if you guys
want to see my full
detailed comparisons and click above to
subscribe to see more videos like this
one and help us reach 600k subs before
our official two year mark that would be
awesome thank you guys for watching and
i'll see you in the next video